i've been asking to get your guys
comments on this past weekend's ufc 254
habib beating justin gaichi do you guys
think he is the greatest of all time
over
uh ped jon jones because jon jones put a
tweet out
saying i'm the greatest of all time i
think
oh you can go first babe if you want
it's very difficult it's not difficult
for me because i tweeted a couple days
ago what'd you say
i said khabib go that's it
and you know i'll be honest with you is
khabib's
style the most exciting style no you
know
but he did something that was very
interesting the last game
fight um which you know to me
you know if i was khabib i'd just be
like i'm gonna have to take this guy
down right away
i'm not gonna be in a stand-up war with
this guy but i have to be honest with
you
khabib beat him on the feet yep
that's what's scary about it could be
beat edson barboza
on the feet same with connor and connor
anybody he faces
and he faces them down on his feet first
yeah at first
and he knows that he has this unbeatable
style
once he gets his hands on you it's over
it's
the ticking time bomb right there's
there's just something about
his innate talent that he just knows
weight
and control his body control he just
it's just an
account that he has and he knows that
once he has a hold of you it's over
and yet he chooses to stay on his feet
for a bit
and still win right to me watching that
fight was
you know the people go tony ferguson
didn't get a shot
yeah i i i don't think he can do i don't
think anybody
can beat him and i can't say that about
jon jones
you know when he fought reyes i thought
that reyes won i thought he won too yeah
i honestly did
and you know that two judges scored
um in the first round for geichi
that's insane that's weird that's insane
because what we saw was that was weird
i was watching it going it just just it
reminded
and also in awe of the way khabib
you know i mean fart geichi because
geichi is a [ __ ]
beast i love he's a good egg he's a good
guy he's a nice guy you can tell i would
love to hang out with him
he reminds me of somebody that could do
our podcast and like bisping you know
yeah just that kind of a nice guy i
think it'd be great we would love to
have rose nominees as well
just throwing it out there and um but my
point is is that
um to me that fight
solidified that khabib
is the greatest of all time here's how i
i
i would listen to all the things that
jon jones said and while
he made valid points i think the reason
that
he can never be goat to me is that i
think that
goat is more than just the record
like it's it's it's you you have to like
embody
the spirit of a champion and i think
that jon jones is
not that like i think that he has a lot
of
demons that there that he's unable to
overcome and like from where we stand at
least like jon jones when he first came
out
was my favorite fighter i i never missed
a jon jones fight
but you know he i i don't know it's it's
hard to love him man like it really is
like you you want to rally behind like
the sheer
obvious talent that he has but i just
there's a champion has more than just
that and i think that
at least for me habib was you know
always embodied that to be in the top
10 of all time you know i mean is a
difficult
imagine all the fighters right you have
george st
pierre there's just millions of them
right oh yeah anderson silva right you
have so many of them
and jon jones could be in the top three
of all time i mean that
who who is that who can really say who
the greatest of all time is
there's no way to really prove it
there's no metric right because jon
jones is undefeated as well
he has one blip on his car but that was
he was beating that guy
matt hamill yeah matt hamill um but um
yeah it's just um you know i have to say
though
i was kind of a khabib fan
you know but i think that last fight
made me go
my god what an anomaly what a
talent what a an amazing fighter
and he seems like a nice guy too you
know so you know we'll see professors
before
justin gates he said that he would never
tap and then he said that
he didn't want gagey's parents to see
him
hurt or like break his arm so he
switched
the submission into a triangle
um to put him to sleep instead and also
his dad's favorite submission
and yes yeah well he's he'd rather put
gachi to sleep than break his arm that's
i think what's this yes because you
don't have long lasting effects from
being children yeah but also putting
something
to kind of kill them what would you pick
you're in a situation i would put me to
sleep i don't want to go through your
surgery arm broken over going to sleep
look
sweetie he goes to sleep and he dies
basically no you don't die
he basically assured that gait she could
fight in 12 weeks
like if if gaitry had a broken arm then
he would need surgery and then he'd be
out for like the whole
[ __ ] year unhelpful advice then okay
on hopeful advice with bobby and kalila